bad news for you Jonah he's back so it's
been a long time since I've bumped
Doctor Who off a Sunday slop but I know
if I don't address this now it's going
to be bombarded at me until I do
so the planned Doctor Who video for
today is going to come out on Monday
which means that I'm gonna talk about
fact that Sony and Disney came to terms
spider-man's back in the MCU and a few
other related things to talk about the
general state of things so um if to
recap quickly the initial deal between
Sony and Disney to share spider-man and
how that was going to work where Kevin
Feige helped a shepherd the spider-man
film not the ancillary films like venom
but spider-man films directly over at
Sony and it allowed spider-man to show
up in the Avengers movies and for Tony
Stark to show up in the spider-man
movies which was good for everybody and
in addition to that Sony was keeping the
vast majority of the money being made
off that but they also weren't while
they sell the rights to all these other
you know spider-man related things again
like venom and a bunch of other stuff
that's in development we'll come back to
that they couldn't integrate that in
with the other Marvel stuff it was only
spider-man being shared and that entire
agreement had reached its end as many
films as had been agreed to had been
finished now at the renegotiating table
Disney had wanted to make it a case of a
straight 50/50 split because prior to
that Sony had been putting up the money
for the spider-man films which was why
they took most of the the most of the
income that came with that and Disney
wanted to do 50/50 which they would
stump up 50% of the money for it but
they'd also get to keep 50% of whatever
it generated Sony didn't like that idea
everybody walked away now there was
obviously a
about cry a lot of people lost their
freaking minds which I still think was
unnecessary even if it had remained that
way but they're now back together they
worked it out what is the deal now it's
now 25% of the budget and the returns
that Disney will be taking they'll pay a
quarter of the cost for the next
spider-man film which has been confirmed
to have the director of the last two
coming back and they will take 25% and
that's how it's gonna be now here's the
thing that's sort of weird about this
and I think it's an important thing to
remember the way this entire thing
played out is not very unusual it's
actually really standard for the
industry the difference is the degree to
which the public was aware of it because
these kinds of negotiations whether it
be between actors and studios or studios
and each other or you know directors
with the producer whatever whatever
these kinds of negotiations go on this
sort of back and forth of they come to
the table they say what they want they
say what they want they leave the table
and like so on paper the things dead and
then they reconvene later and move it
forward that's not uncommon that happens
actually a lot almost nothing gets
worked out at initial talks and it's
pretty standard for both sides to draw a
line in the sand walk away and then
decide later maybe we will talk again
and sometimes they don't but and so I
don't want to imply that every single
time there's this walk away come back
work a deal sometimes they don't
actually come back but this whole
process incredibly standard incredibly
normal what has changed and I do think
this is something that impacts the MCU
specifically a bit more than it would
any other franchise though it could
theoretically happen with other
franchises what as well which is that
basically they this whole process
happened in the public view now there's
a couple reasons for this first of all
the whole inner workings of Hollywood
are just simply not as obfuscated as
they used to be not because they're
being more transparent just because it's
a lot harder to keep this stuff
completely behind closed doors these
days and sort of adding to
that is the fact that Marvel and the MCU
is always in the cultural talking points
because there is always a Marvel movie
on the horizon there's always the
speculation of what are they gonna do
what's the next show what's the next
movie how will it connect basically
entertainment media be it online print
or anybody never stops talking about
Marvel so that entire machine is just
it's on everybody's mind already and so
we're already looking at it way more
closely and the fact that it leaked out
I don't think was like any kind of
intention I don't think that it was
actually a tactic but it's just the the
eyes are so tight on this and like by
design Marvel and Disney have very much
made the MCU a continuous talking point
across almost all media that's their
intention that's what they're doing on
purpose and they're very good at it but
this is one of the odd ways that that
kind of impacts what would otherwise be
the normal process of making a movie
because suddenly a lot more people are
watching you're behind the scenes stuff
then normally would be going on normally
this sort of stuff would just be
interested to actual Hollywood insiders
you know people who it's their job
specifically to track the inner workings
of the industry and there aren't that
many people who actually do that but
there are a ton of people who track
Marvel and so we get this weird overlap
where these kinds of negotiations were
normally very few people would care
suddenly a ton of people cared so it was
weird and the way that played out is
honestly not that unusual now there's a
couple of other things that are believed
but unconfirmed but you know and
normally I don't talk rumor but I'm
piggybacking it on to what we know has
happened so I'll just toss some stuff in
there there's word that there will be
allowed some degree of integration of
Sony's extended spider-man stuff with
the MCU now if I were to guess I do not
think that that means we're suddenly
gonna have venom showing up in an
Avengers movie I don't see that
happening nor do I see like something
you know like a Planet of the symbiotes
or somebody that becoming the next
Avenger story that's not I don't see
that happening like especially because
the process of renewing this deal
already kind of
fell apart and then came back together I
don't think marbles gonna want to tie
things any more tightly together with
what Sony's planning to do then they
already have however what I would kind
of expect is basically what happened
with the Marvel Netflix stuff which is
that there will be acknowledgments named
drops just connective tissue that links
them in the same world I would not
expect actual crossovers to happen
although this might make it more likely
that venom or one of these other
characters that they're building movies
around like Morbius and Kraven and the
new one that they're currently working
on again coming back to it um may
actually show up in spider-man's movie
but again I don't think that means they
will ever cross over to the MCU I cannot
imagine either Marvel or Disney or even
Sony really wanting to like entangle
things any more awkwardly than they
already are because then every time the
current agreement expires it becomes
more stuff that needs to be detached and
worked on it I think it's primarily
still going to be spider-man himself who
crosses over it's just Sony might be
able to do more with him connecting to
their other stuff which will then by
proxy connect things like Morbius Craven
and venom to the MCU but again direct
crossover I do not see that happening so
the one of the things that got announced
again let's just piggyback it all
together they're apparently starting
work on a Madame web movie which is a
very weird idea like not necessarily
from Stone from Sony this is the same
studio that wanted to make sinister six
movie made up a villain that hadn't been
introduced in the main series yet and
we're planning to do a prequel starring
Aunt May as a spy so like they're
tossing out a lot of weird ideas most of
which have not moved forward but some of
them are now and it it's a we again it's
a weird idea Madame web is kind of
difficult to explain but long story
short she's not a character you would
actually base a story around
she's a connective tissue kind of
character she's never had her own book
so far as I know I mean maybe a like a
one-off or a miniseries that I'm unaware
of but she's never headlined her own
book and she's the kind of carries
generally not every interpretation
because she's shown up
in cartoons or whatever but generally
speaking she's blind
she's precognitive she's got some level
of psychic whatever and she sort of has
this interconnectedness with spider
characters and that's kinda it like I
said she's a connective character she's
the kind of character that used to bring
to people who might not otherwise have a
reason to cross paths together through
her or interactions with her she's very
good for that
but building a movie around her at the
very least building a movie around her
as the actual main character makes
almost no sense for that I'm massively
working for what she is what makes a
little bit more sense though is if they
wanted to make her the connective tissue
of basically linking more spider related
characters and in effect to end up doing
a live-action equivalent to into the
spider verse not necessarily like a
literal direct equivalent where you are
crossing dimensions or whatnot but if
they wanted to use her as the pivot
point to introduce a heck of a lot of
other spider characters in live-action
the way that into the spider verse
introduced a heck of a lot of alternate
versions of spider-man in animation she
would work for that is it a good idea no
I really don't think so but I mean
that's the only thing that I can think
of you could actually do with her um
there's a little of other stuff going on
Kevin Feige is going to help with the
next spider-man movie which I mean who
knows what it's gonna be called they're
gonna have to come up with something
with a home name we've had Home Coming
and far from home next one could be I
don't know it could be home again he'll
be home alone that'd be fine but
whatever it ends up being it's it's
going to have you know Tom Hollands back
to the directors back and Kevin Feige
helping with it again which means that
we can expect consistency with the
previous spider-man films and I think
that was the most legitimate fear is
especially because when we found out
about the deal falling apart previously
the director hadn't been firm confirmed
to come back yet so what the big fear I
think or at least I think the most
reasonable fear was was that when a
third spider-man movie happened which of
course was always going to happen that
it would feel disconnected from the
first two that had a consistent creative
team behind it and that Sony would just
plug whoever they could get into a third
just to get it made thankfully now that
it's very much not going to be the case
does that snow suddenly mean every spite
in my movie forever is gonna be great
well who the heck knows we're still
getting venom 2 which is being directed
by Andy Serkis which I'm kind of curious
about and the first venom was fun it was
dumb it wasn't great it was very
outdated and it's approached everything
but it was fun there were certainly
elements worth pulling out and building
on and the main one of those elements is
the relationship between venom and Eddie
and so when your lead character dynamic
is like the best thing about the movie
yeah you can build a better sequel
around that we'll see if they actually
do and of course Morbius is still moving
forward oh and like whoever the writers
are for Morbius they're working on
Madame web as well which also makes me
nervous because it always gets me
nervous when it looks like someone's got
even gotten a new screenwriting gig on
the strength of them having written
something that hasn't come out yet that
always makes me nervous because I don't
trust studio executives to have a good
sense of quality because what studio
executives tend to really like in
scripts are things that could that
connect to marketing and sale ability
not necessarily a good actual script so
like if a hire screenwriter delivers a
script that has a ton of marketable
characters and a ton of franchise
potential then studio heads tend to love
it until the movie comes out and sucks
and they're like oh crap but you know so
like that makes me a little nervous just
because it smells up putting too many
eggs in in too few creative baskets when
it comes to the whole spider-man
extended films thing but it's still
early days for that so who knows
the venom 2 movie might be significantly
more polished the Morbius movie might
even be good I think that one has
potential to work as a standalone I
don't know who knows who knows what this
thing's gonna go but regardless
spider-man still gets to be in the MCU
and the third spider-man film will have
the core creative team back in place so
everybody relax and you know just chill
like I said this is actually business as
normal we just normally don't have eyes
on it standard stuff what are your
thoughts on this whatever they are drop
something down the comment list
about it there's other stuff down there
as well link to my patreon help me out
it'd be really appreciated plus you know
subscribe to see the videos when they
pop up there's the Bell as well if it
helps you the like button is a big help
when you folks hit it it does actually
help me out there there's other links
besides click on them do things or don't
you don't have to cuz I'm not gonna tell
you what to do because at the end of the
day you're the council I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]